learn lanterns with deaths of more than
a hundred and eighty thousand pounds
alex is on the verge of losing
everything he's got that's quite excited
that's why I'm here to find out what's
gone wrong
chef chef thank you good and this is it
it is and don't it's it's small pokey
yeah very [ __ ] al Scott executive
chef I like those yeah team in the
kitchen yeah to us too so that's why the
executive what's with the flags they
tell you in English and that's the style
of food its own and you're from
it's like England Oh England that just
always worked in the timing kitchen so I
just sort of learned to learn the
language the style of cooking so lots of
lieutenant ingredients yeah we're the
courgettes from from our butcher from
London this morning but cool yes from a
butcher yes
and then we're the peppers from Tesco's
Tess Cox a cheaper are the cheaper so
courgette to the butcher the peppers
from Tesco's lemons from Sardinia you
carry so so far I've seen four Italian
it's Saturday the only busy night at
Lanterna a chance for me to take a close
look at Alex's authentic Italian kitchen
packet better than our sauce that
reminds me of my days as a hotel comic
back in the early 80s a successful
Italian kitchen has to understand the
secret of great Italian food simple
fresh Italian ingredients the microwave
in Alex's kitchen all the vegetables are
precooked
and blasted in the microwave everywhere
like Christmas tree decorations we need
to do our sticker on the top shelf we've
got a fairy and what do you do in ponent
we working on the chemin Tax Office so
why cook in great start
opposed assistant who won't cook and an
English chef who seemingly can't
but the menu promises is modern Italian
cuisine and at 30 quid a head has got to
be good to keep the customers coming
back nice matchmakers the packet
grissini matches the deck or straight
out of 1980s fake Italian trattoria to
see what Alex is made of I've asked them
to serve me up some Italian classics
first up fresh minestrone soup this
should be a star hit on any Italian menu
very very greasy yeah
dirty almost around the outside I'll
pass another one is there there's
parsley on the stalk next
Sal CC lagana fresh Italian sausages
baked in white wine and served on garlic
bread and it looks like two penises
doused in parsley I almost like Phil
I've gotten back to sort of 1982 where
every other restaurant in the high
street making Italian ripoff
we're now in the 21st century
sorry crap like this - disgusting even
worse the amaretto cake is bought in and
unfortunately it's not quite defrosted
slightly frozen the center oh dear this
is about as authentic as a [ __ ]
Chinese takeaway right Alessandro you
talk passionately about Italian
ingredients authenticity I saw nothing
you tell him and nothing done with care
I'm concerned about where you're going
how long this place has got to last
and unfortunately delivered [ __ ] all
that was babe way way below do you think
it's just funny no okay because I didn't
find it funny that was upsetting
because that was [ __ ] die